maintenant je suis fier d'avoir
représenté le papa que j'ai été pour les
enfants qui m'attendent à la maison
voilà je pense qu'ils vont être fier de
moi aussi et que que le pape a été au
bout du bout de lui même et a donné tout
ce qu'ils pouvaient voilà un peu un peu
déçu et fait qu'il manque pour aller
jusqu'au bout c'est toujours un peu
toujours un peu amer de ne pas terminer
ce qu'on est venu fermer malgré tout et
mon aventure était vraiment belle elle
était peut-être un peu mal parti vu les
performances que j'avais au départ
physiquement et film mais quelle montée
en puissance est montée crescendo réel
20 aventure je n'oublierai jamais ce à
quoi jamais donné c'est une destin les
deux agriculteurs de l'est s'en vont
ensemble terriblement déçus mais fiers
de leur parcours et de leur section et à
l'eau
merci c'est gentil merci d'habitation ou
alors on est content de le voir nous et
on aime bien tous les candidats de koh
lanta mine de rien on l'est on les aime
bien on aime on aime l'esprit koh lanta
on va pas se mentir moins serrés que
vous balade dans koh lanta vous soyez
pas une demi-journée de penser que vous
pourriez pas bien sûr elle est sur qu
elle rassure mais c'est quoi abbas a le
moral pêcher ses terrasses fermées
il reste pas grand chose mais c'est
bonjour je suis très bon plan nord c'est
le plongeur à la maison la très très
grande longueur très très grand blondeur
ya jacques mayol et moi on a fait les
poteaux pendant 2h30 coiffer les poteaux
pour deux heures et demie qui la
pagaille sur les routes ne regarde pas
ce qu'il voyait pas bien le poteau
mercia avec nous tu étais un des
chouchous a été éliminée serré vendredi
alors on ceux qui suivent y a plus
vraiment le chouchou la maintenant dans
les ep moins de trois beaux aventuriers
tu es déçu armes ou pas bien sûr bien
sûr on est toujours déçu quand on quand
on donne un objectif qui est là dans
cette aventure la dalle et de sécurité
allemand de prêt ouais ouais tellement
près mais tellement loin aussi pour le
coup c'est vrai finalement on marche sur
le poignard sans jamais le trouver et
puis et finalement ouais ouais donc
c'est le stress de trouver la course
d'orientation
c'est le truc mais c'est sûr et certain
de rester huit ans sur les installer
plus de plus de quatre heures on a couru
quatre heures alors je la par rapport
aux images qu'on a vu effectivement on
le voit marcher tout mais non je cours
quand même allé fort couru rien
transpirer
c'est un truc de fou
et j'ai même endroit sur la carte qui
est un peu vide
je cherche une plante comme ça mais y en
a partout à chercher de l'herbe
il faut vraiment que je veuille ça j'ai
la grosse pression
qu'est ce que je fais je sais pas ce
fait quelle galère je sais pas du tout
si tout ça sur la zone ça me stresse
stressant car je n'arrive pas à lire ma
bouteille d'eau sur une pompe je suis du
coup tu vois ça me fout les jeux stress
non natation match y avait une fâcheuse
tendance à perdre un petit peloton
comprenant les moments difficiles
[Applaudissements]
c'était peut-être à cause du stress mais
là c'est une petite boulette c'est qu'en
fait tu t'es trop leurs couleurs j'étais
pas le singe était précieux quand même
sérieusement pour moi pour le coup
j'étais pas le seul mais c'est vrai mais
quand c'est ouais c'est un peu le stress
aussi et puis je savais que je devais
pas tout seul à chercher à chercher la
borne et du coup il y avait lucie
n'était pas très loin de moi j'ai vite
fait regardez j'ai vu que j'avais trouvé
j'ai vu du blond mais c'était du belge
qui était pas de loin et du coup mais
bon c'est pas forcément ce qui m'a coûté
ni du temps ni rien d'autre c'est
simplement le fait que j'étais perdue
sur l'île finalement en qui m'a coûté un
peu pour voir cet extrait regrets
[Musique]
j'ai trouvé d'abord content je vais
essayer de retrouver la plage
je vais repartir parlant
alors
vous allez trouver quoi 22e non non non
il n'y a pas de couleur blanche
le coup
[Musique]
j'ai pas regardé au bon endroit
alors je crois comprendre à redon
regarder la couleur sous le nombre de
pas c'est la couleur d'un côté et vous
perdez pas une minute
[ __ ] con au label non je pense pas
c'est bon sens ce prêt pour perdre un
peu de poids jean ray garde pour lui
mais sinon ça marche mais on leur prend
assez rapidement car en direct on
perçoit bien là-bas polenta moi j'ai
perdu 11 kg en ce qu'il ou elle a repris
combien moi j'ai repris 9 peut-être
j'aime bien dire que j'étais en pleine
forme à la sortie que j'étais plein de
formes là où on est déjà dans koh lanta
c'est commun de la tête et rester comme
maintenant on est resté 35 jours trente
cinq jours alors il ya aussi un autre
truc sur toi c'est ton début d'aventuré
qui est marqué par une petite polémique
qui a sûrement suivi celle des animaux
donc toi tu es un terrain baroudeur
quand tu cherches tu as une technique
assez particulière c'est que le problème
c'est que vous avez chassé des raies et
que ça n'avait pas plu du tout à tout le
monde
o'malley même parlé ici c'est vrai et
ikea qui on voulait arnaud d'avoir
chassé derek valait 2 les deux voilà
voilà
vous n'avez jamais mangé de rêve on and
on est pas un taquet comme ça maintenant
on va revoir
on va voir mais posez vous les bonnes
questions
je pensais m'approcher pas trop loin et
puis pouvoir l'a planté avec mon bâton
mais c'est très rapide voudrait voilà
c'est complètement raté
on fera mieux la prochaine fois voilà
temps
l'art est trop rapide arnaud a trouvé
une autre proie
on vient chercher
on y court avait chopé la jafza qui n'a
jamais qui n'a jamais bouffer une ré
benhaim talibans oui je non je n'ai
jamais vous vous êtes peut-être expert
en retz en tout cas moi je ne le dirai
pas comme ça toi on est content que vous
voir et ben moi je suis fâché de pouvoir
reproche
et là je suis vraiment pas content tu
sais que vous avez chassé
ok c'est un jeu il faut tuer des animaux
a fait lui avec un peu de pudeur un
petit dealer il va le rugby va même jour
avatar se joue à expiration à éclairer
ses confitures
on fait ça discrètement ma faim on voit
là je veux dire combien des caméras tout
le temps sur sa 2e et bien contre le
fait de tuer l'animal mais en plus de ça
si c'est fait de manière aussi violente
aussi violent cela ne me plaît pas et
c'est pas un bon message à passer aux
gens qui regardent et aux enfants qui
auraient alors alors je vais vous dire
donc oui ça veut dire que quand il va
les manger mon colonel vous allez vous
faire dans la pudeur a pas de bonne ou
de mauvaise manière de tuer en a mais je
suis venu manger
en plus ces séquences elles sont là pour
crédibilité y'a pas de mauvaises
manières mais les faits n'ont cessé donc
c'est pas hyper grave c'est le cri de
l'animal c'est vrai des trains était
maintenant on parle pas d'une vache ou
d'un ou d'un chien ou d'un cochon dans l
art est un peu et c'est hypocrite de
dire ça la finalité est la même et que
l'animal meurt la différence entre les
uns et les autres
ben oui oui oui je fais des cobayes sont
dans les déchirements bouderait ou une
vraie l'elysée des animaux qu'on voit
dans des élevages s'achemine vers la
finale à la maison ça se passe
ces courriers des choses à n'importe
quoi c'est une séquence pour
crédibiliser l'émission ils n'ont pas de
quoi chasser ils font avec les moyens du
bord et son apport pour pour pour se
nourrir et dont ils se nourrissent doré
il est là je suis d'accord avec kelly
sur le fait de gangs quand vous avez dit
y'a pas de magna pas de bonnes manières
j'ai enlevé sushi est ce que tu te fais
la passe de trois mais est ce que vous
mangez chier ce que vous savez par
exemple comment le ton comment le son du
jeu derrière les poissons sans savoir
comment ça se passe je suis d'accord
mais on voit énormément de chose de plus
en plus on est de plus en plus au
courant de ce qui se passe de ce qu'on
mange
mais oui mais pas dire on est on sait
pas ce qu on s nommé aux grammy sûr que
la limite est gelé sur de survie c'est
normal j'aimerais que les sports la rdo
quand même passé vous parlez tous ceux à
sa place donc annoncer sa wii nommé
comment on fait comment sont faits les
sushis et compagnie moi je le sais pas
non plus une ce que je sais moi c'est
que j'ai fait laventure que c'est une
aventure de survie on survit des
dissidents comme enjeu des tués si vous
m'aviez donner une canne à pêche ou un
truc je sais pas comment on fait maturer
à la csn
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
ce que je trouve le plus terrible c'est
le cri dollar et inquiet tu trouveras du
trot du travail à droite
est-ce que ce soir non non non moi c'est
assez marrant quand même du crabe à
savoir que simplement cette riche pour
le coup je n'ai pas touché non plus non
j'ai pas touché à aucun moment elle est
vraiment trop rapides que tout chinois
s'est passé était 2 masculine ou
féminine
non c'est la première fois que touché
très touché pour le coup mais si je
l'avais touché c'était la première fois
que j'entends je parle pas c'est moi
tout va bien je sais excuses que je me
tourne c'est exact mais effectivement
vous ne savez pas comment faire autant
je suppose que les animaux qu'un canton
dans les fermes ou samexpo du temps là
les crabes tout ce qui existe aussi et
ça même pas qu'on sait quoi ça sert ou
pas c'est vraiment qu'on fait avec ce
qu'on a fait ce qu'il a à dire pas grand
chose du coup c'est des polichinelles
j'ai été très choqué quand même parce
que ce sont des rêves ou n'aime pas mais
quand même vous jetez une machette sur
une ré ce sont des raies pastenagues qui
ont été introduites
elle serait valorisée à face mais pour
aller vers les touristes donc l'art elle
vient gentiment vers lui au contact de
la borne accueillis par des raids sur
les manques lp clp
j'ai acheté machette c'est pas une
méthode ça continue c'est trop violent
la bonne méthode gina c'est quoi la
bonne méthode lui il fait avec son pif
en charpie fluide et puis c'est pas vrai
c'est ça la bonne mais censé protéger
celle ci en puissance du tout le monde
moi j'aimerais qu'elle soit protégée
dans tous les matins animal dans un
endroit non mais ça devrait être logique
on aimerait tous que toutes les règles
soient protégés et a eu une histoire
aussi sabrina ça vous êtes 200 vous êtes
déçu ça vous tue peut toucher toutes ces
polémiques et ou pas du tout non ça m'a
pas atteint
oui je sais ce que j'ai fait a bien sûr
fait de mal à personne d'ailleurs je les
ai pas touché
et si je l'avais touché c'était pour la
manger effectivement enfin passons mais
pour celui qui grille machine qui nous
je suis pas comme ça quand j'ai jamais
regardé un peu notre mission est
justement un coup moi je suis pas comme
ça le plus dans ma vie voilà je fais pas
de mal mais il ya deux semaines chez moi
je vais attaquer l'arrêt
y a un truc aussi sorti s'est tarie de
petites stratégies tu voulais éliminer
toutes les filles n'ont alors on regarde
et tu me dis ok inquiète pour moi je
suis inquiète pour maxime parce que si
maxime elle vient à partir il est très
très mal
mon aventure sans elle serait très très
dur donc voilà l'étau se resserre à
c'est vrai qu'on a un peu en panique
garçons nés bien soudés jusqu'au
prochain élimination je pense que ça
peut te dire pour moi je voterai pas un
gars sont encore en egypte
arnaud ont-elles réseau de se dire que
chez les rouges leurs jours sont comptés
lui de venir va pas se mentir je suis
éliminé des femmes ça a un côté maxis
peut-être d'années extérieur et ce qui
n'est pas le cas c'est que ça s'est fait
deux fait petit à petit avec des
affinités ya du rythme
j'ai rencontré des gens avec qui je me
suis bien entendu il y avait au départ
pas forcément un stand aventure oui que
maxine avec nord avec jonathan avec
l'uci avec vincent que vous avez reçue
le lieu où je suis allé manger cher mais
je touche ou des réseaux sociaux rend
tout le monde vous adore ouais ouais ce
gentil c'est vrai que nature exacte
ouais c'est vrai je triche pas quoi
c'est comme je dis les gens qui me
connaissent dans la vie nous retrouver
dans l' aventure les gens qui m'ont
découvert dans la voiture ont appris à
me connaître
vous vendez plus de légumes qu'avant
alors non parce que j'ai un certain
volume et j'ai déjà des clients pour ce
certain volume et comme je peux plus
rester à échelle humaine et je veux pas
ou aussi beaucoup plus que ça trop
rapidement star il va y les maraîchers
il vend des légumes serait sympa
maintenant que c'est une vedette il va
vendre plus
ouais bah si c'est d'accord mais c'est
vrai il ya eu un avant et un après
encore que moi dans mon petit village
était pas déjà une honnête mais tout le
monde j'avais déjà un look intérêt qu on
se dit voilà
ouais ouais c'est ça c'est vrai qu'on
l'a maintenant même avec le masque
effectivement on à chevelure me
travailler un peu quand même vous après
pau le prochain astérix
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
moi si j'avais été je te jure je
l'aurais mis franchement je trouve que
c'est un arrêté qui alors du coup pour
faire clic unique 6 e mais qui vend du
poisson puis bout du nez légalement ils
vont prendre mes progrès vous l'avez
dans la gueule
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est pour moi en tout cas merci à tous
pour vos qui va gagner
qui va gagner il va gagner la finale
mais témoin les trois finalistes yoplait
enrichissez pas trop vous demander
alors qui va gagner maxine jonathan le
lous vainqueur il sera avec nous la
semaine prochaine pour que peut-être
même tout le monde doit mettre en
section attend j'aimerais beaucoup vous
vous étiez entraîneur de l'époque du
poteau non non non mais moi je m'étais
entraîné pour rien en fait c'est vrai
ouais quoi quand on va faire que
longtemps on se met pas sur un poteau
pendant des semaines et des semaines
ah non non non non non non j'ai été
courir un peu plus avec mon gâché un peu
la piscine puis surtout vous êtes parce
que moi c'est vrai que je me dis avant
de faire koh lanta même si j'y
arriverais jamais je fais que du poteau
mais maintenant on peut déjà y arriver
aux poteaux comme la série a déjà plein
d'étapes quand même à passer
moi je vois là je prenais les étapes les
unes après les autres j'avais fait un
beau parcours quand même ouais ouais je
suis vraiment content de mon parcours
même si j'avais mes mais le loup ampleur
dans mes bras vendredi bien sûr
malgré tout j'ai fait mes loulous
ampleur ce qu'il était fan de vous ah
ouais ouais super bon ben on retiendra
acheter des légumes
là pas de soucis tous et bienvenue car
50% sur le berger
[Applaudissements]
[ __ ] et j'adresse adoré ton naturel
voilà je te lis voilà je pense que
c'était le chouchou dans l' aventure
aussi c'est parce que voilà tu étais les
mecs qui étaient tt voilà tu es un mec
qu'on aime ou on aime bien les mecs
comme ça voilà qu'ils sont mais ça finit
quand ce truc parce qu'ils sont passés
[Rires]